hey guys how's it going happy tech
tuesday today i'm pretty excited because
i'm about to unbox for you guys the new
hero 4 session so if you're uh
you've just completely missed the memo
gopro came out with a new camera that is
basically
half the size of their previous one
which you're probably asking yourself
why
i think the answer is because they can
let's unbox this thing thing that i've
learned from previous gopro unboxings is
you don't need a knife
unfortunately
let's open it
hopefully i didn't want to return it
i'm rolling to best buy excuse me i'd
like to return this what happened to the
box oh i don't know my dog ate it
geez i should have had some sort of
grand reveal
oh shoot
so many surprises so
many
surprises
you look nice though you look square you
look really
you look thicker though cute
tiny
square
and you pop them right on out
what are our specs on this thing
i think we might have lost that piece
so let's just do a little comparison
so if you took this little guy
squished him together just like this
it's basically the session
what's this do
is that's how i turned you on
oh
i turned it on okay well i didn't
actually want to turn you on
sometimes things happen
sometimes things happen that are out of
our control that little flap just flips
it right up you've got your micro sd usb
so the session uses the micro usb and
the previous versions use the mini let's
give you a little light
shed some light on the situation
so let's put in an sd card
okay now i need a knife
look at you you look so little you're so
tiny
it goes in on a slant make sure you guys
are careful when you put this in
stick you in
close you up it's the smallest and
lightest gopro yet
okay well
it feels exactly the same as this one
what is good is this is actually
waterproof already which is kind of nice
because sometimes when you have to add
on those bulky other cases onto these it
can get a little frustrating if you're
just kind of like all right it's time to
roll out
and you gotta put the case on this you
don't have a case
i like that you can just push this
button and it turned on and it's already
recording good job gopro one of the cool
things about most cameras now is you can
connect them all to wi-fi so you're able
to actually view what you're seeing on
your cameras on your phone and that's
why i absolutely love all the canon
cameras that i've been using recently
also because i can connect this camera
this camera to my phone hit record focus
and do everything that i need to do and
then it tells me to push this button
just doing what you're telling me to do
things are happening
pairing it's got its nice little blue
light as you can see to let you know
that your wi-fi is on and then i'm gonna
go into the gopro app oh here you are
you can see
here
what you're seeing
you're so tiny
what am i gonna what am i gonna do with
you to recap this is the previous
version of the hero4 this is the hero4
session so i'm sure many of you guys are
probably wondering which gopro camera is
right for me and that's kind of a hard
decision if you're not really sure what
you're going to be doing with it what's
great about this one is it is small
clearly it's pretty tiny and you don't
need an external case on it so it's
already waterproof which is really nice
but the problem is it is 399
which is pretty much the same exact
price as one of the hero 4 silvers this
is the hero4 black if you need to go a
little further depths this one is
waterproof up to 131 feet whereas this
guy is only waterproof up to 33 feet so
really you need to take into
consideration what you're actually going
to be doing with these things but i
would recommend that if you've never had
a gopro you're not really sure what
you're going to do with it the entry
level gopro is pretty awesome it's only
129 and it also has the lcd back so you
can see what you're shooting i will tell
you that if you've never shot with a
gopro before getting those angles
precise and actually getting things in
frame can sometimes be a little bit
difficult which is why i do like to be
able to connect it to wi-fi if i'm
filming because i don't know what i'm
filming because you can't freaking see
i'm going to take this little guy out
and probably do some vlogs with it so
stay tuned for that and yeah let me know
what you guys think i'll see you guys in
the next video happy tech tuesday i
don't think it's tuesday today is it
no
it's not
see you later
okay half a cup